how's it going my brows welcome back to
mystery chapter two or three I think it
is actually so if you touched a mattress
it starts lagging and apparently so
oh my god so many mister shares I love
it what have you been there's bells
everywhere and statues I don't like this
situation all right let's read this good
result all our patients have been doing
really good so far
they may even be able to let out soon I
have no idea what they are all
progressing so fast I don't trust you I
don't trust you mr. Sher help me
alright I'll are interested for him for
you know gosh yeah like bounce
what are you doing there's twos going it
nah this is impossible
it's like divide by zero it's not
possible this is pretend that didn't
happen
did I miss something in here I get the
feeling I miss something
so many doors all right no okay let's
just go spawn it all right this way pity
all right let's go here huh don't close
on my door what happened here ah
totally I'm and so many times let's sit
down here
no I should go in hello hello ah look at
this corridor this is not good Stephano
i guard arts this is taking nice and
easy
hi oh thank you in here pity look it's
nothing absolutely nothing I'm seriously
disappointed
keep going pity in here don't forget
okay oh oh you're perfect
I got so much I didn't give me that much
action all right let's keep going oh
you're ready pity are you ready for this
are you really ready look at me look
look at me okay fine fine I'm ready okay
can't go there hmm mmm hi nice guy [ __ ]
Oh what was that oh this is Dori
exploding doors I've seen that before
actually I never huh okay they say they
care for it it's up to this place what
is that
flowing drum okay I'm gonna put you down
spawn handle will click this I expect
bad things right now
ah wow that was also not closets I'm
climbing no you didn't come back and I
need okay he doesn't see me he doesn't
see me cause it's closets oh okay we're
in the closet wait again I'm in the
closet yeah why is it has it oh I have a
Latin Adam um again how again oh oh
there's penis pulsation everything let's
just go and I guess yep oh oh here oh we
good
oh my god oh no no pollen I just need to
follow yeah I just can't find myself to
find him all right
let's see Savannah anyone here kind of
close to be the light I am not gonna lie
it's pretty damn low though ah really
I hate these drawers take forever to
lose probably nothing in these honestly
I'll just skip the first one okay let's
go here let's make sure no one follows
see me I don't trust any of these guys
so creepy oh okay hello let's try it
this one pretty cozy uh hello mr. Sher
hello hey we've been waiting for you why
don't you sit down over there why the
way you want to talk yeah we have to
talk pity I should share you up finally
kept sneaking up on me alright fine we
got the machine room key I don't even
know where the machine room is but
probably not in here alright I hate this
I don't just yeah yeah I don't specially
don't pass yeah I'm serious
pissed off what is this anyway that's
the point of this room aye sir arm just
arms
final four close the door or our mate
armors and barrels maybe it's in here
they're starving don't trust yet
Oh what's going on here okay they like
what they did to me I can't move
uh yes you like that you like when I
touch the floor
Hey Hey look at my birthday I did
exercise do you like it look at it baby
it's around and flashes okay I'm
thinking no I don't have the key oh you
take my bullet treatment ah
Oh water ah that's not good either it
took man I got a touchy spot okay let's
just go here oh man he's like dad and
all of a sudden he's like I don't
okay we're good okay I'm just gonna go I
don't even know anymore
no I'm gonna go over here actually I
changed my mind
okay yes yes no yes yes yes yes all
right I fell down this hole that's what
she said
that didn't make sense it's overwhelming
dockets I recognize when ad they stumble
upon that the thing the thing I created
must expire damnation the most
extraordinary creation of mysteries
chapter 2 completed you're like my
dancing all right that was Chapter two I
really like flames three smiles they're
always fun to play good job bro I hope
you enjoyed like and favorite and all
that kind of good stuff thanks please
mod yes come instant to make another
shot there they're always really fun and
yeah I think that's pretty much it
haha alright how's it going brahs I bet
you thought the video was over I didn't
yeah alright I was told that this
machine room key has a secret in the
closet so I wanted to check it out at
all speedy I am stay father
I reckon oh no I didn't I play with this
instead it would have been hilarious oh
wow that's really whoa I am huge this is
a problem the ladies man Keith you know
they like me bigger man anyway I
probably couldn't have climbed up there
anyway but yeah this is awesome pity I
am just as tall as you are and look the
barrels no problem no problem alright I
hope in the next small things does he
keep Savannah this size
alright thank you for watching bros I'll
see you later
I am Stefano
[Music]